[Music]
hey I'm Mark Wahlberg here at 45 or
tonight I'm gonna teach you how to get
guns like Kevin and not too tight so
eyes or hip flexors
those are little pistols though that's a
strength baby okay car oh yeah oh yeah
watch out Dwayne the rock Johnson he's
coming for you it's not the world we
live in now brother
well the great thing is I mean you can
start at any level of fitness you know
if you're a beginner you can workout at
your own pace modify the exercises and
you know slowly build yourself up the
great thing is no matter what when you
put in the work you're gonna be the one
that gets the results and you get the
benefits of all your hard work it's
interesting because it's different than
normal gyms because in a normal gym
atmosphere you go in and they're like
lift as much as you can they're yelling
at you you know your boys like come on
we need more it's a very difference like
like you said a community
you know everybody's working together
you go to a gym I got a box jam people I
have headphones on nobody's
communicating with anybody
nobody's interacting good I'm gonna tell
you I felt a little weird at first and
everybody kept sticking her hand up to
give you a high-five or say come on
let's go and I was like yeah yeah yeah
we're good let me but it really is a
community thing oh man I got to the
point where I'm so about talking
everybody find out what's going on how
people are doing what they did during
the week that I was the weird guy
showing up to other people when f45
wasn't open yet I was going to another
gym and I was literally going up to be
like first of all is that who I think it
is you know you just find that it's like
it's it's a place where people are
welcomed and and there's a support
system there
I just got benefits from working out and
doing this workout this is no joke I
mean the circuits all have you never you
never stop moving
that's the crazy thing who's asking was
asking the ones are gonna be over you
did good
no I feel good yeah I feel and I'm not
like beat up yeah right now make sure
you stretch stuff cuz you're working
muscles as you probably haven't worked
in a while
yeah who you telling yeah and here's the
crazy thing
did you do a leg workout before this did
you go into a whole leg workout before
this did I'm uh you know again I'm a
little bit crazy I'm gonna play an
extreme athlete and adventure racer in
the movie so doing a lot of cycling and
stuff like that so we did a little 3
a.m. leg workout before we got here so I
need you to show me three moves so I can
get arms like Mark Wahlberg look bad
those wait right there okay is that your
size I mean I went a little light but
it's okay listen I don't know where
you're going so a lot of people will
just like do a lot of questions it's
fine as long especially don't sit down
and do kind of like just don't do this
don't do these only a little lunge and a
step up to it okay so you do a curl so
when you step up on the box curl and
then press it over the head Oh get that
leg up there okay all right here and
then press press touch that's no joke
here press and then you know whatever
let's see so you're doing a curl the
legs that's a lot that's why I went
right that's good okay take this behind
your back behind your back
yeah religion this I'm gonna say what
you're gonna are you gonna do oh this
and if you want it always yeah you can
tighten up that rope - I'm the band yeah
you could say get a little chassis
though for five steps how many of those
should people do 10,000 no I would say
it I always do like three sets of ten
twelve depending you know I don't know
anymore had enough injuries for
everybody I'm trying you know
so the lesson is you don't need to go
heavy you just need to do the work so
we're gonna do the same thing right so
use this as the line yeah we're gonna go
with a curl press curl lunge curl lunge
press
and I tell you mm-hmm anything where are
you going full-body there's gonna be
much bad for you but with Wayne yes a
little bit away and again you start
building yourself up easy baby get down
on that box you have to modify don't you
huh like that and that'll help get the
back of arms yeah yeah triceps it again
you still kind of fart alright I'm you
know that's why they're my squad kind of
you know that's called Tiger mortgages
right here that the hip flexor so is the
hip flexors are high that's the key
stretcher got a stretch him right me
with cuz it's bad
yeah but you have a tendency to fall
forward yeah all right nobody's stead of
sitting there tighten up pulling down
your back yeah yeah these things are
tight like a chance I got like this
coffee okay anyway come on take your
hands like this
okay this one fix my back pretty hard at
this so when you squat down come down
here and your heel come down here okay
okay alright hands across the chest I'll
get all the way down okay
keep going keep going
you gotta when you get down here
mmm-hmm you're gonna press off the heels
and come up that's hard work
[Music]